I guess that's why flying would be
better than being able to read mine not
if you're afraid of heights like I am I
don't need to tell everyone that hey
you're late sorry
saving lives hey Carl how are you hey
pretty good actually I just said wait
wait this time or should I say when were
you well have you guys heard of the
great New York oboe fire 1814 no exactly
anyway I think the best power would
probably be invisibility because I know
I'm supposed to play it cool and pretend
like you're like everyone else even
though you're a superhero but how does
it work
Allison come on Quinn doesn't want to
talk about work at brunch time is a
closed loop everything I have done and
everything I will do has already
happened so I can't change anything I go
back in time when something in what we
perceive as the present goes wrong and I
need to fix it
but to you the present stays the same
because I've always gone back in time
yeah I mean I know all that so so
basically it's not risky at all because
you've already done everything a billion
times
well I was on fire but if I went back
with you that I don't know
March 27 1976 nothing bad would happen
what happened on March 27th 1976 that's
the night my parents met for the first
time in a diner quite like this my dad
says that she hit him like a bolt of
lightning or an arrow right through his
heart
can you imagine the power of a love that
strong yeah I can can you anyway I'd
like to go back there now please you
traveling through time wasn't part of
the plan you're a simple human if I take
you back there you would shake up the
dynamic of that diner in the
catastrophic ways
you you and your mom look identical
right so if your dad is into your mom
why wouldn't he be an IU
I hate time travel what if we went into
the future instead I'll take that fully
balanced meal sorry get your guy I'm
telling you guys we could make millions
I mean the food industry here's know
bootstrap paradox you could shake up the
entire system for the lamest reason ever
I've got it we go back in time and kill
the worst person who's ever been born
got a gun in my pocket
am I just happy to see you it's a gun
hey do not that hot it's Hitler's murder
paradox something worse will absolutely
happen trust me you shouldn't
time-travel so why can you do it because
he's an actual superhero it's my
birthright my responsibility I could
never let you do it what happened to me
I want to break up it's not you it's her